[screams]
[laughter]
[upbeat music plays]
- I'm going to shotgun a
beer for the very first time
at 23 years old.
- When dudes are really drunk
and then they pull out keys
and they're like "Let's shotgun"
that's when my brain's like "Don't do it."
- I hope I don't vomit everwhere.
- Uh, step one
Put a hole in the can.
There's already a hole in the can.
The top.
- Mouth on hole, finger on tab.
I feel sexual already.
- Keep horizontal.
Which way is horizontal?
- General Safety:
Don't underage drink!
- [Voiceover] Proper
utensils for making a hole.
Anything sharp.
- Like my wit?
- Please don't drink and
drive, 'cause that's stupid.
- So wait, as soon as I
like, put this and open this
is this just going to shoot into my belly?
- I never knew that there
was a science to this.
I thought just drunk people did this.
[music plays]
- I'm so scared.
[expletive]
[screams]
[music plays]
- I knew I would be good at this.
- Ohhh.
- I can't do it.
Wait, let's try it again.
[coughs]
- Sorry
- My lips...are burning.
[burps]
- Oh God, I messed it up there.
- Can I get this for my Tinder profile?
[roars]
- There's no attractive way to do this.
Nobody's getting laid here.
- That was fun. [laughs]
[music plays]